hey everybody welcome to the podcast
I've got two very special guests today
my friend
Byron Davis joins the show he is a
former USA Swimming national team member
and incredible human being and he's
joined by Phil Allen jr. who is a pastor
he's a poet he's a filmmaker he's a PhD
candidate super interesting guy and
today we're gonna talk about all things
black lives matter it's a super powerful
potent conversation hope you guys enjoy
it so without further ado this is me
Byron and Phil enjoy gentlemen welcome
thank you for doing this thank you man
this is great it's good to have you guys
here so why don't we start with just you
guys briefly introducing yourselves kind
of what you do and then perhaps we can
pivot into taking a 10,000 foot view of
where we're at right now okay my name is
Phil Allen I'm a founding pastor of Anja
Faith Ministries in Santa Clarita
California I'm a second year PhD student
at Fuller Theological Seminary studying
Christian ethics and theology and
culture mm-hmm and my focus is dr.
King's theology and ethics as well as
the intersection of race theory and
theology hmm so that's my my study of my
research will Center on that I'm an
author and filmmaker just produced a
short film open wounds but my
grandfather's murder in 1953 family
never got justice and it talks a lot
about intergenerational trauma from
racial tragedies and systems and
structures and where do we go what do we
do now mm-hmm
I tried to find the film online I
watched the trailer but it's not it's
not publicly available right now right
yeah yeah yes soon soon uh-huh yeah but
I know the I know the produces I can get
you a link all right now
[Music]
I'd like to see it and what does that
mean Christian ethics maybe explain that
a little bit just ethics you know we
have terms like social ethics ethics in
particular context but it's just a
biblically informed the scripture
informing that the ethics then how we
like right now how do we respond to a
murder that we see on on camera for the
world to see how do we respond and
ability informed manner to this how do
we respond to what's happening in
politics how does a Bible inform that
mm-hmm
so yeah it would seem that everything
that's happening right now like your
your whole life and everything that
you've been studying has been preparing
you for this moment yes yeah yeah I
wasn't gonna release the film I was
trying to get it in film festivals and
when this happened people who have seen
it except screen did a few times in LA
said you gotta show the film you gotta
show the film right and and I've thought
about it this past week and I said you
know what this is the time and there's
there are other projects I want to do
and so maybe this is maybe this is what
this is for we did it in six months
right we filmed edited produced and
screened it within six months mmm raised
funds and so maybe this is this is what
that was for yeah I support that I mean
I think you could take it to a bunch of
film festivals which now are all on hold
or don't exist anymore for you know a
couple small audiences or you could
release it publicly and attract a wide
amount of attention yes to the issue I
mean essentially the film is about your
grandfather who was you know without
mincing words lynched right and kind of
getting to the bottom of what happened
and how that you know played out and was
covered up yes yes and and how it
affected my grandmother
sixty years later she's still the trauma
was still there she can couldn't talk
about it in and how it affected my
father when he found out that his father
was killed by a man that lived a few
doors down from them mm-hmm and it
changed his life and so that was the man
who raised me or who was my father
right so therefore there's gonna be some
things going on in my life that I'm
dealing with because of what's been
passed on to me and I had no idea in the
route of it yeah and so I started to do
this research and I realized where the
pain my grandmother's pain was like why
she was the way she was right why my
father was the way he was and it
actually led to having more compassion
for my dad when I first found out this
we didn't have a good relationship and
there was a lot of forgiveness that
needed to happen oh my boy because of
the trauma that he experienced that got
passed down and wasn't ever fully
processed or communicated to you in a
way where you guys could get past it
yeah my father he never had you know we
had a conversation a few years ago where
he was healing or grieving his mother
and my uncle his brother's death which
was like seven months apart and I asked
him do you think you are grieving your
father's death too he said I never knew
my father I was too when I was two right
and I said that's my point because you
know domestic violence I grew up in
domestic violence they saw it for the
first 15 years of my life my father had
drug addiction alcohol addiction anger
serious anger problems and and there was
hate in my heart towards my dad and so
when I found this out
then it was like wait a minute he was
nine when he found out he's probably
still processing this like what would I
do if I was nine years old and I found
out that my father was killed
yeah right so
it led me to to forgive the story was
that he fell off a boat or something
like that
they say he fell off the boat but my
grandmother told me her father went to
the funeral home and until the funeral
director don't do anything to the body
until I get there and he got there and
he saw the bullet hole in the back of
his head or neck mm-hmm
his body came up a couple days later and
so they know it was murder and then I
recently found out a man who shot him
confessed it before he passed away
someone knew him and he was in his later
years and he confessed I guess he felt
he could trust that person right and he
confessed it but he's no longer here so
right yeah yes so it's a justice that
could never be redressed and what does
that do to a you know a young man at age
nine when he finds out and how does he
carry that throughout his life and and
pass it along yeah yeah well I want to
get into that a little bit more deeply
but Biron mm-hmm we go way back yeah we
go way back I'll be quick of course even
rich you and I you were at Stanford I
was UCLA swimming and you know I'm a
former athlete turned speaker consultant
Phil and I became you know good friends
and brothers when we were both on staff
at a church called Shepherd Church out
in Porter Ranch but we've been connected
for you know close to 15 years now in 13
15 years and both of both he and I you
know didn't necessarily start out in
this journey of becoming activists in
this issue but by nature of you know how
he grew up how I grew up
it's and even in the climate that we're
in now it it it just makes sense and you
know I think part of our mission and our
goal our heart is to elevate the
conversation around race
and around
you know superiority around racism and
you know just around people groups of
people in their silos constantly
pointing out you know the wrong and
other people and causing so much
division that we don't get smart minds
on all sides working together to
actually address and deal and ultimately
heal the problem right he's so humble
man this is like lay it out for people
that are watching or listening like
Byron was Byron's legend like this guy
was an incredible athlete yeah you know
incorrect were you the first
african-american to make the USA
national team actually I know there was
one person right before him and now I'm
blanking which is terrible
but yeah it was I was one of the first
right and just three tenths of a second
separated you from becoming the first
african-american to make a USA Olympic
team and swimming I was there and elimin
trials I watched that race because mark
Henderson was my you know do you make
way back but I have and we talked about
this and Byron was on the podcast in the
very early days I think it was episode
17 and we went through his whole life
story so I encourage everybody to go
back and listen to that to get a full
you know picture of your life but you
had to overcome incredible obstacles to
you know not just become the athlete
that you became but to become the man
the father and the husband that you are
today and I got nothing but you know mad
respect for you know that journey that
you went on and you've always comported
yourself with just tremendous grace and
and just composure through what I would
imagine you know was incredibly
difficult at times and the fact that
you're you you kind of just you know
didn't even mention any of those things
I just want to make sure that people
really understood like I remember you
know we talked about this before but I
remember being at swim meets and seeing
Byron on the deck and he was just the
guy was like a Greek guy watching this
guy professionally and so I'm you know
honored
be your friend and to have you guys here
today so why don't we I want to get your
perspective on on you know what's going
on right now from like a 10,000 foot
view like how are you perceiving the
current climate and series of events
that we're seeing unfold like rapidly
like everything is accelerating very
quickly right now but give me a sense of
kind of where your head is at I the
first thing that comes to mind is pain
is manifesting itself particularly for
the black community because George Floyd
represents a lineage of black bodies
that die senselessly it just so happens
there was a camera to capture it and I
don't know many african-american men
particularly that don't have stories
whether its police officers or civilians
where it could turn ugly it could lead
to something like that because you come
across people that just want to flex
Authority or superiority I've got those
stories mm-hmm matter of fact this this
last incident impacted me harder than
the others because well what's
interesting is I I realize on Thursday
just a few days ago that my body
responded when I saw the video but my
mind did not understand why this thing
was so heavy until a few days ago so
when I saw it there's this response here
that this traumatic response to my body
and my mind knew that this was heavy I'm
crying doubt the day I can't write I
can't study and read and in a few days
ago I realized this is why because it
took me back 19 years to my personal
experience
in New York being pulled over profiled
and it didn't lead to brutality or
anything but he was instigating me to
cop he told me what he could do there's
nothing I could do about it
and he stood in front of me he stared at
me and I guarantee you if he stood in
front of me today I could if he was in a
lineup I could point him out 19 years
later so I never forgot that look so
when I saw the cops eyes that's what did
it it meaning meaning like I'm the one
in control here and then this this this
evil one is hate like he was looking at
me like he despised me and it was he was
like he was in my face right here maybe
not even this far away and just staring
at me and I wouldn't bow my head I just
stared back at him and when I saw the
cops eyes it reminded me took me back
and I said that's why this is so heavy
for me there was something just so
brazen about it and casual hmm and there
was awareness there was an awareness
that they were being filmed and it
didn't seem to matter and I think that
is really chilling yes yes and I just to
add I think one I am grateful that it
was finally that was finally captured on
video because events up into this point
again this isn't the first incident of
police abuse and brutality that's been
caught on video but what was caught was
you had a police officer who in his
posture had full control over the
situation and intentionally decided to
put his hand in his pocket and stand in
a position of dominance over this black
man until the black man died capturing
that with other officers with other
officers danis of that and one officer
you know timidly even suggesting hey I
think we got this under control and him
like no you know you're a rookie on the
job you go over there
you know that all was captured and I
think for the first time in this age of
social media more people actually saw
that not the black kid running away and
being shot you know or brutally being
beat up and we come in halfway through
the video destroyed on the Nira right we
were able to see that I think that's in
addition to pain I think it also evokes
a lot of anger among the
african-american community because this
is what we speak about behind closed
doors all the way to the 21st century I
I'll never forget my son right before he
went off to college II is a freshman at
USC now he and I in sophomore year had
the talk and what what's the talk it's
the talk that black men have with their
black sons and nephews about how to
engage in an encounter interact with the
police if you're pulled over or anything
of that nature
mm-hmm I actually had to have a the talk
with my son mm-hmm that's going on for I
mean we can't even count right there is
a palpable sense that this is an
inflection point and what you know
allowed this moment to you know capture
the attention of the world and in such a
huge way I you know seems to be unclear
like is it is it that it seems to be
that it's the confluence of a bunch of
these events happening in you know
serial fashion
all of a sudden compounded by you know
people being cloistered in their homes
and jobs being stripped away like
there's a rawness right now to everybody
that I think has contributed to this
just being an extraordinary flashpoint
mm-hmm for not just America but the
world and I'm interested in whether you
think that there is the possibility that
this is going to be different we've been
year before we were here in Ferguson in
2014 and there was a sense that things
were going to change and they didn't
really change the world was paying
attention very closely for a short
period of time and then it moved on I'm
sure in 1968 there was a sense that we
were going to emerge into a post-race
nation and we've made progress but we've
fallen far short of that mark so do you
feel like we're now in a position to
make the changes that are necessary to
make and and what are those changes I
think we are I'm I'm skeptical but I
think we have the potential to make
significant change like you said we've
been here multiple times before that's
one reason why I'm a little skeptical
but we if we don't make the mistake of
just simply responding to the incident
the moment like that's the only thing
that we're responding to and then once
it dies down we think everything is okay
maybe justice is served and they go to
the cops to prison and the family may
get some money and so justice is served
so now let's move on I think this is a
moment where and I say this all the time
to the white community to be baptized to
be immersed in a culture a history
perspectives that are not your own so I
talked to I'll teach a class or I'll
I'll preach or have a workshop and one
of the things I hear when the most
consistent things I hear is I never knew
that because I usually will do a survey
of history to walk us go back and bring
us to this point
so people can get context and people are
stunned because they never knew they
never knew Emmett Till they never knew
about the amount of the extent of
lynching they never knew that veterans
african-american veterans from the war
world war two would come back and many
of them were lynched because now they
were a threat there they have been
empowered as
and they wanted equal but they would be
lynched or killed or beaten
what-have-you and people just didn't
know the extent of this mm-hmm for
whatever reason they think is just these
particular isolated incidents then the
systemic the structural the
institutional racism the laws and
policies from decades ago that we're
living out the legacy of today that
perpetuate disparities along racial
lines where that it doesn't need to be
an individual doing something the laws
and policies do them for you as a frame
that is the definition of systemic yes
right it doesn't matter the narrative
that gets spun is there is no systemic
racism I'm not racist
I don't have racist friends but the very
definition of systemic means that you
don't have to be individually racist you
can opt out of that completely if
nobody's racist the system is
constructed in a manner that still leans
towards favoring those that have against
those that have not it will continue to
repress the African American community
until it's deconstructed and rebuilt
with checks and balances that ensure you
know proper equality and freedom for all
yep and that's okay well one other thing
I think one thing that is different now
is it's not just black folks angry like
when you go to youth protest like you
said you see everybody there now my hope
is that from this the bat that's why I
use the term baptized now immerse
yourself in understanding how we got
here because if we don't we will
compound the issue mm-hmm trying to fix
it especially trying to fix it really
quick mmm we'll just compound the issue
because we don't understand it fully so
that's why that's one reason it gives me
a little bit of hope this is different
because the people who I see are are
angry and out there it's multicultural
not just primarily black people yeah
that has been a big difference go ahead
write histories always been told from
the perspective of the victors right
right people who can control the
narrative and so when you when you look
at the the foundation in the history of
the United States of America
it was founded on the backs of slavery
okay I mean even when you just go all
the way back to when you had the
Europeans coming over and in in conquest
and adventure it was economically driven
right it was all that the foundation and
when they tried to initially enslave in
indigenous people and Native Americans
that didn't work out very well because
Native Americans knew the lay of the
land they could you couldn't keep them
captive and they found an economic model
that was actually going to work and so
from the very beginning of our history
all the way through up and through today
you see the the systemic scaffolding of
white supremacy embedded in the system
and you know you you ask the question
you know can there be change there there
won't be change until those who have a
vested interest in keeping the status
quo the way it is are willing to
challenge their own worldview and when
their blind spots are actually pointed
out have the courage to change because
then that's going to actually shift a
lot of the power in a lot of the
privilege that exists even to today yeah
people don't like to do that though
exactly exactly right and and that's
where it's scary yeah and and so when
you when you get this this narrative a
good book is is book called white for
town fragility by Robyn D'Angelo Robyn
D'Angelo thank you that actually speaks
a puts a lot of good language and
articulates this big fear that many
white people have about confronting
their own racism because you don't
necessarily have to be a person that
hates overtly hates another person's by
because of their skin color
- still perpetuate racism you just have
to recognize when you are asserting
yourself and catch yourself or one has
to catch themselves
on what is the benchmark in the gold
standard or the norm by which they
define and rate everything else you know
my daughter for instance yeah you know
when a white kid comes up to her not
meaning anything malicious and tells her
you look cute for a black girl hmm
right right it's it's it's it's this
idea of wait a minute
I'm comparing her beauty to a standard
that I'm not even aware that I'm even
comparing video clip that was going
around with the the Australian
newscaster who was interviewing that the
twin women who who I think there were
twins and they came from a mixed race
mixed race parents and one looked very
white and one looked very black and and
the newscaster was complimenting the the
white looking twin and saying you know
good on you that you got the one you
know yeah it's that yeah that is
prevalent and that's baked into every
facet of our system I can only speak to
my own experience as a white privileged
male and you know I can tell you that
that I've had to do my own
soul-searching to look for where I've I
was gonna say like gone arrived but I
think that's the wrong phrase like more
where my blind spots are and all of this
you know have I done an adequate job of
ensuring that I have a diversity of
voices on the podcast and what are the
things that I'm doing you know
throughout my daily life that I'm not
consciously aware of but yet are part of
the problem right and I think you know
one of the things that I've been been
struggling with over the last couple
weeks as somebody who has a platform is
how do I communicate about this and what
I've what I've noticed in myself is a
resistance to speaking because I don't
want to say the wrong thing or I'm
afraid that if I say this it's going to
be misinterpreted I don't care about
people being you know
like the people the trolls and all that
like that that doesn't bother me at all
but I do want to get this right and I
want to make sure that I'm affected in
my communication and I think that that
but that fear of of needing or wanting
it to be as accurate as possible has
prevented me from speaking up or as or
as frequently as I could and and and
should be doing and I think that's
something that's probably you know a
common thing that a lot of you know
white people have right now so you know
what are what are the questions like
what is the right question to ask right
now like if you're speaking to a white
person like what are the things that
they should be thinking about and how
can they contribute and participate in
this in the most effective way you know
I think a great question is should be
asking how did we get here because I
think a lie I listen to a lot of people
speak as if they have the answers again
because of this event and recent events
and the anger that you see is not just
because of these events
this is anger that stretches back 400
years because when we as an African
American in our community when we see
something happen it's never just about
the thing that happened mm-hmm it's
typically about the history this is
another thing that's happening so it's
like this a subjects a natural thing we
don't just look at our burries situation
we don't just look at George Floyd or
Brianna Taylor mm-hmm we literally it's
like it's like a file that you just
recall the faces and names like that or
I could go back to Emmett Till
immediately I can write personal
experiences yes personal experiences so
I think a good question to ask is how
did we get here and I don't think enough
people asked that question I think for
one one reason it's gonna force people
particularly white folks to look at this
country differently it's gonna force
them to these are my white fragility
with D'Angelo's talking about it
it forces them to look at themselves
because to be American
subconsciously is to be white mm-hmm
right and everything else is measured
against that I'm I've had people Syrian
conversations where a guy would say
yahwah's honest at this room and it was
a bunch of people die first you know and
I you know Americans were there and then
he began to list the african-american or
the black folks Hispanics they weren't
American I guess right but he when he
was a an American he was telling my the
white folks that were there anything he
wasn't a bad person
it was great guy but subconsciously he
just associated American with white
that's typically what happens and so to
look at how we got here is to now have
to open up yourselves to seeing this
country differently because I always
asked a question when you say America is
so great what's your definition of
greatness and when hmm because if you're
talking about power like military might
and prosperity certainly if you're
talking morally and being a just society
you have to have to go back and help me
understand when was that because there's
always been systemic and legalized
oppression in this country there's never
been a decade and never been a time in
history in our history that it wasn't
the case and so I challenged that notion
of greatness do we have the potential to
be absolutely and so I think how do we
get here is a great question to ask and
in addition to that also I think people
have to this is a time of courage a time
of intestinal fortitude where white
people also have to confront their
ignorance when when we don't know
and that's exposed that's vulnerable and
it doesn't mean this this goes beyond
race this is just human nature right
human condition if if we're not
something if we don't know something and
and and our
current idea or point of view or or
answer that we thought was true is shown
not to be by just based on evidence
that's a very vulnerable position to be
in
okay no one likes their their ignorance
exposed but if you look at that even
that term ignorant from just the sheer
educational definition ignorant is the
beginning of of enlightenment it's a
it's learning you have to you can't
learn until you confront and wrestle
through your ignorance right that's what
that's the foundation or the
fundamentals of learning so adults have
to embrace and the the fear and the risk
of being vulnerable you know when when
they what they may say out of just sheer
ignorance is is proven to be untrue well
it requires a certain humility right oh
and I'm uplifted because I'm seeing a
willingness to embrace this conversation
in a way that that I can't recall in my
lifetime and that that gives me hope
but it's juxtaposed against a climate
and a culture that is more deeply
entrenched in there in being right and
they're silos and you know the division
that we're seeing right now I it's it's
sort of a war between those two things
right now you know social media
fomenting this division across America
where people just want to yell at each
other and no one is taking a pause to
actually listen and take stock and you
know perform a little bit of you know
forensic self analysis it's it but I
think these events have led us to a
point where we are seeing a certain
portion of the population doing that I'm
attempting to do that here today and I
think that's really the only path to
healing and to into really
reconstructing society around more
equitable lines mm-hmm rich I think
you're totally right you hit the nail on
the head you you have to be willing to
have those kind of conversations when
you can get when intelligent people are
are
duck in their silos and their echo
chambers and and spend more energy
trying to defend their position then
admit that this is a multi-faceted
complexed problem that is going to take
rigorous and consistent attention to in
order to really write in order to really
solve the problem until we're willing to
really embrace that then it's it's gonna
be an uphill battle it's gonna be hard
because we are we we feel more
comfortable when we think we're right or
when we have the upper hand
and so when you have people on all sides
digging in and you know having good
points on every side but spending most
of our energy trying to point out where
and why the other side is wrong as
opposed to instead of being on opposite
sides of the table coming together on
one side and actually pouring all of
that energy into the problem I think
that's that's that's the heavy lifting
that has the conversations like this is
a start but I think what what a message
we want to continue to to really
advocate is after the protesting after
the new cycle you know has died down
after you know the the shift and
attention moves to something else will
we have enough boots on the ground
committed to to wrestling within the
trenches to right the wrong that we
clearly see right now yeah that energy
has to get channeled into some kind of
productive change that that is you know
architected around strategies and
tactics to actually you know adapt the
changes that are necessary rather than
just you know sort of outrage that just
dissipates into the atmosphere which is
again why you hear people really
pointing the spotlight on the
dysfunction within the the justice
system yeah and you get a lot of people
on one side saying you know that's just
those are just bad apple cops
and deflecting the attention on no this
is just if we look at it in terms of a
virus this is just a flare-up of of
something that you know it's still alive
on the inside and what we're seeing is
just a flare-up happening but if we
don't if we just deal with the the
surface you know issue and not deal with
the root cause on the inside it's just
gonna be a matter of time before this
little thing heals but in months weeks
years another flare-up happens so we
definitely have to to take this
opportunity to now do some some deep
dive surgery into the systemic issues
that allow this thing to exist mm-hmm
yeah I think listening to you Byron I
think one of the things to look at is
the power dynamics when you come to the
table which weights on my division and
heats not everyone wants to be right
when you come to the table you have to
relinquish power because it has to be a
compromise well as an african-american
man I come to the table
I'm already I'm already behind already
I'm at the a marginalize already I don't
want to let go of power whatever power I
do have I need to have that one to
protect myself at this table to speak up
for myself don't have much on a white
person comes to the table they're used
to having power not even not as an
individual necessarily but representing
the group that's in power and they get
to decide how much power everybody else
has right and that's uncomfortable if
you have to relinquish that to come to
the table to have discussion right so
it's uncomfortable for both sides it's a
power struggle right and so I don't know
how you I don't know how you self-police
that I don't know how you hold each
other accountable but that's that's
that's what I'm hearing cuz I know when
I come to the table mmm I'm coming
girded up because I don't know when I
don't know when the next time I'm gonna
be at the table mmm I don't know what
decisions are gonna be made there's
gonna live so I have to
with my power my agency and then my
white brothers and sisters when they
come to the table they're used to being
it's natural to be in that position I've
been in these meetings before even in a
church where I see this and I have to
flex I have to assert myself because if
I don't I will get crushed and then it
becomes this battle mmm and then I'm
looked at as the person who's out of
your a being so good yeah angry black
man right right and I'm like no just
because you're composed and I'm
passionate over here I'm frustrated
because you have this power and you're
trying to assert that impose that upon
me and I'm not letting you so I'm the
one that's out of control I'm the angry
black guy and so that's where the the
struggle comes I just had a conversation
with a pastor recently and it didn't go
well I mean it was bad and I didn't know
I didn't really know the guy but it was
bad and I saw the power dynamics in here
mmm
right and I wasn't going to relinquish
mine because I wasn't gonna let him
dictate for me one how I should respond
to this
George Floyd situation I was gonna let
him dictate to me my understanding of
racism like literally this is all I do
every day every week other than
bald-faced racism and these systemic
problems that have created these
institutions that create inequality a
huge obstacle or opposing force to black
lives matter is a huge swath of
underprivileged disenfranchised white
Americans who have lost their jobs or
are seeing you know declines in their in
their ability to make a living etc who
are who are hurting and it seems to me
that that's the most activated group of
people who because they because they
feel like they're there they're not
being heard right so their natural
inclination is to voice their
you know anger in an unproductive way by
opposing this movement yeah and I think
you have to on some level that like that
that has to be addressed in order for
everybody to come to the table to
compromise I suppose so how do you think
about that issue rich I want I think
it's a great point to bring up but it
goes back to a point that Phil you were
making earlier and this is where getting
an accurate perspective of history is so
important when you look back on even
after you know slavery was over and and
blacks were able to in especially
different pockets go out and actually
start making a living you know they got
their own land started opening up their
own businesses actually started thriving
I mean under underneath military you
know protection at that point support
but they were actually thriving and
starting to grow well one of the the
sectors that really began to feel the
brunt of this new shift in opportunity
in power was the the lower-class white
community of which the Klu Klux Klan was
but was burned and born because even
back then they started seeing and
feeling and interpreting their lack was
coming from these these these black
people who are taking their jobs right
like a zero-sum game like a zero-sum
game like empowerment and advancement
was right at the cost of their own
empowerment exactly X's and O's or you
know binary this whole binary
relationship in that and that's not true
and you continue to see that throughout
history and not just with the
african-american community we can we can
talk about the Asian community and in
red the railroad transatlantic railroad
does built and how there was a huge you
know skiff on employing Asian workers to
build the railroad and by the time the
railroad met in the middle of America
you look at the picture of the two sides
joining and the big picture of all these
men they were all white faces the Asian
community who actually bill
that from the Pacific all the way to the
Midwest no no no sign that they were
even involved in this whole process
because all the way through you had
disenfranchised White's attacking people
who thought were taking their
opportunity away so you're definitely
right what what's being felt now is is
again another symptom of a dysfunctional
structure that has to be examined and
looked at rigorously it's not an easy
answer and on top of that when you have
not getting too political with this but
but when you have voices recognizing the
divide and then throwing fuel on or you
know gasoline on the fuel to keep the
division necessary it doesn't it doesn't
help the problem but but I hope that
that kind of speaks to to why it's so
important for for us to again really
take this you know take the long this is
the long game that we have to be willing
to to wrestle with and and then look at
you know why are a lot of white commits
traditionally white communities
suffering white lower crest class
communities suffering well it's not
because blacks or Latinos are taking
their jobs it's because the system that
actually created economic opportunity
maybe in that environment or that that
local area has shifted so there's it's
not coal any longer it's not an
industrialized support system or
infrastructure that's generating the
revenue for that community things have
shifted automation a lot of things have
changed that has now taking dollars in
cash flow out of that community and so
we've got to look at that we have to
look at this problem in a very
compound-complex way and then in the
process of solving the problem together
be willing to look at our blind spots
when our blind spots are exposed mmm
yeah let's go back a little further
1600s mmm-hmm right lingers around 1680
this is one of the things that should I
give you understanding white supremacy
is a very exclusive originally a very
exclusive club it was white and wealthy
so the lower-class of the working class
the poor whites actually had more in
common with the with indentured black
servants and slaves back in the 1600s
than they did with the merchants and
there was an uprising I think Bacon's
Rebellion there was an uprising this is
when the term white became a legal term
and privileges became attached to it and
this is how they divided the the African
Americans the African slaves or having
indentured servants and the whites the
white poor whites the if you're white
you could have property you could vote
you could be a citizen you had
privileges this is where we start with
the white privileges and so that divided
because now the poor whites saw
themselves on the hierarchy here and
blacks were here we're not like them
well just a few weeks ago we were this
and so white supremacy actually crushes
its own but there's such an allegiance
even from poor whites to whiteness and
its privilege its superiority it doesn't
see that they actually have more in
common with other marginalized groups
because white supremacy by nature is not
just whiteness but it's wealthy right
and and that would get a power struggle
it'll it'll crush anything that's not in
that group yeah it'll turn on each other
hmm
because it's built on greed and avarice
and when you could have a person who
remains nameless position himself as the
blue collar billionaire from you know
it's when you you have a person who's
able to in his own narrative and his own
campaign to put the presidency hijack
the the the the narrative and convince
those who were marginalized who had no
nothing in common with this guy
you know to then vote and you know allow
him to be the voice of their
disenfranchisement if I if I can say
that what's brilliant from a marketing
standpoint it was brilliant because he
was able to do that and then point their
angst in there their anger toward again
other marginalized groups I mean we saw
we see this even back in the days of and
I'm not comparing Hitler to Trump by any
means but we can see what what was it
that allowed Hitler to create such a
strong narrative that permeated outside
of Germany to the rest of the European
world and demonize you know the the
Jewish community well it was a narrative
of pointing the finger at all of these
Jewish you know merchants and business
owners and saying they are the reason
why you're poor they are the reason why
you don't have opportunity it's them and
and that message that narrative was
allowed to again echo and echo and echo
and pretty much before you know it and
even the the minister of propaganda you
know of the the Nazi movement says if
you tell a lie long enough mm-hmm the
masses will believe it yes certainly
he's a master of creating reality out of
his own you know
delusional narrative and energizing his
base by putting a face on what that
enemy is and without expressly saying it
but through every action and everything
that comes out of his mouth yeah it is
you know gasoline on this fire and you
know I think it's gonna blow up in his
face and I think we're seeing that right
now my hope is that this is gonna
energize young voters to turn out I mean
just what we're seeing in the streets
right now I've never seen public
activism on this level and so I'm
hopeful that change will come in
November but if we've learned anything
right there's nothing off the table
right now in terms of what what could
happen but his ability to leverage that
anger and sense of disenfranchisement
for his own personal gain and do it
under the rubric that he is in their
interest and is one of the great
snake-oil hat tricks of all time yeah
definitely yeah I was just with actually
having a conversation with a good friend
of mine who happens to be a very
right-wing conservative Christian he and
I were on a conversation a long
conversation and I just share it was it
was a thought experiment you know I
decided I asked him I said hey let's
let's let's do a thought experiment
really quickly he and I were roommates
at UCLA freshman year okay and he came
from Iowa and I'm from inner city East
Cleveland okay both coming together and
having the room together and learn a lot
about each other through this whole you
know first year at in college and I and
I shared with him I said hey look let's
put race aside and and let's just look
at this from an aspect of privilege I
said you and I were athletes who were
blessed to get scholarships to UCLA
correct and he's like yes and I said
well you know be honest
what could you have gotten into UCLA on
sheerly your SAT scores in your GPA and
he was like no mm-hmm right and I was
like well guess what join the club me
too we were both there right here's a
white guy saying the exact same thing
and I said guess you and I were
beneficiaries of the privilege that was
extended to us in the form of an
athletic scholarship you know our our
names were were put higher on the list
of Admissions because of some perceived
value that we were bringing to the
university that's privileged that's the
privilege that you nor I deserved yeah
we can both make the argument that we
worked hard in the pool we got
and we demonstrated that that we were
good enough to compete at the college
level sure that doesn't take away our
effort at all but what we have to really
recognize and be honest about is if
there was not an infrastructure that
valued swimming at the d1 level enough
that they were willing to say we would
love to give you you know equivalent to
your tuition and books if you decide to
swim with us if that construct if that
infrastructure didn't exist we probably
wouldn't be able to get in mmm but you
might not have put so much energy into
being a good swimmer had that
opportunity not existed like in your
horizon right yeah you might have
channeled your energy in a different
direction and I kept saying I should
have been a basketball player so that's
interesting though this idea of how of
how Christianity fits into all of this
and another juxtaposition with how
Christianity has been leveraged by the
right in a manner that contravenes the
the core principles of what this
religion is founded upon and yourself as
a pastor and and Byron as a former
pastor like let's talk about that like I
listen you did a you did a sermon like a
recent podcast I'm not okay that I
listen to where you kind of break all
this down and you don't pull punches at
all
in that which I appreciated so where
does faith play into this politically
and also spiritually with respect to the
movement that we're seeing at the moment
well two things one I think we have to
be honest we've been deceiving ourselves
into thinking that we are practicing the
Christianity that that's in Scripture
American Christianity looks very
differently and it's intertwined with
Americanism its individualism capitalism
I just wrote a paper um I think one turn
into a book one day neoliberal the
neoliberal gospel and it's it's a
business
all right and we forget about we get the
fact we're in a people business actually
so I think I think the way we we live
out Christianity we have to be honest
that we're far from and I'm pretty
critical about the church we're far from
as a group living out what we see in
Scripture
it's very Americanized but as a pastor
what I'm seeing happening is I'm seeing
trauma
I'm with yeah you said earlier we
witnessed a lynching a public lynching I
had oh I had a guy come up to me once I
preached a sermon and in the last couple
of years almost everywhere I go I weave
in justice into it I shared my
grandfather's story older white
gentleman comes up to me afterwards and
says he's in tears and he says I have to
confess you know my grandfather was he
has pictures in the house of him
standing in a crowd proudly smiling in
his a lynched black body hanging behind
him when he was younger or maybe when he
was adult oh no no he said those
pictures are all around the house were
all around my grandfather's house
growing up they were just normal that's
crazy yeah yeah he's in tears and he's
apologizing but he doesn't know what to
do with that and what I'm seeing in this
man I had to get past my offense to that
and it wasn't hard I was in pastor
pastor mo but this man was genuinely in
tears broken what does a child seeing
that what does that do like our souls
aren't meant to see that and be normal
or experienced it or engage it and be
normal what we saw was a public lynching
two weeks ago
that's not normal to move past that and
not address the pain the woundedness the
trauma that wouldn't be normal so for me
I think that we can't and I see too many
people trying to fix the problem they're
trying to rush
fix the problem well how many of us have
ever been in a relationship with someone
who's wounded like deeply deeply wounded
and end up being toxic then had to be a
romantic relationship it could be a
friendship they're just toxic right well
they're still dealing with some stuff
that they've never addressed in their
lives they've never walked through the
healing process and I think it is
critical right now that there be intent
we be intentional as the church if we
say we're about those core principles
that we tend to the wounds of those who
witnessed this this lynching and I see
too many people in the church they say
nothing about the murder their focus is
on the either the looting and the
violence there or their focus is on
trying to what's the word I want look
forward trying to debate against this
idea of systemic racism mm-hmm and they
they weave that into politics they made
it politicize it yeah they spend more
energy there and he's a I'm I'm detoxing
my social media as we speak I'm saying
keep posting keep posting so I'll know
who to unfriend I don't want that in my
you know yeah I'm detoxing me I'm like
there you're not even open okay I'm on
Frank I don't want that in my feet Yeah
right maybe I shouldn't unfriend me I
should just unfollow that they could
still see my stuff like I want to deal
with theirs right here's something to do
just to continue to add so what what
what does the church do like feel I'm
I'm coming down pretty hard on the
church because if you if you just look
at the life and teachings of Jesus you
can't be so so gripped on your
ideological and political beliefs
whether you're from the right or the
left to the point where you forget about
what Scripture teaches you about how to
engage
in love your fellow man your fellow
brother and sister I mean that's I mean
that the foundation you know in the the
the message of Jesus and his teachings
is love and if you can't start there at
all and I'm not just being like the
kumbaya type of you know let's we all
get along I love you I don't see color
I'm not even talking about that I hope
you see color I want you to see color I
want you to see the differences because
that's I think where the beauty is what
what what I think is important is if you
care more about your political posturing
and positioning more than you do about
being an example and a model a vessel of
the love that Jesus actually died for
then your religion you know is is death
its mute it's dead
because because that's not what he lived
and ultimately died for mm you know so
that that's that's that's the voice or
that's my my charge and encouragement to
the Christian community is hey we're
supposed to have the playbook to lead
through this time right now right we're
supposed to be the ones that people can
actually look to to see how do you bring
two people who have different ideas
totally different walks of life and come
together in a way in a supernatural
miraculous way I mean the church should
be leading the charge yeah what are the
moral and ethical guideposts right that
are gonna dictate how we navigate this
land field right and I love the example
the analogy of the wounded friend it's
like if you think of a friend who's
deeply wounded or has suffered
tremendous trauma and used that as a
stand-in for the african-american
community how do you interact with that
person do you come to them and say well
I'm gonna fix you with these three
things and we can talk about you know
how we need to overhaul policing and
police brutality and there's you know
several steps that we can take towards
redressing that but that's not going to
heal that wound overnight you come to a
wounded friend with
compassion and with understanding and
with patience not with a motivation to
change or to fix but to understand today
to your point I think about this story
the Samaritan man the man is left on the
side of the road to be beaten dr. King
preaches on this a brilliant the
african-american community for the stake
of this conversation is the man left to
death to die on the on the road the
Samaritan man well the church is the the
priest and the Levite who walked to the
other side leave him leave him laying
there don't want to touch I'm just
washed the other side the Samaritan man
is supposedly like this person who's not
connected to God like the priests and to
Levi but this person comes and gets to
gets to his knees and tends to the
wounds he's taking a risk because there
could be some other robbers hiding out
waiting for the next person to walk on
that road and he's taking a risk by
tending to this man's wounds he takes
this man and puts this man on his animal
while he walks to the end so he's now
sharing resources and he's giving up
access to those resources to a degree he
gets to the end he says here's here's
for his stay so he gets better and in
whatever if he stays longer charge it to
me I'll take care of it because he has
the resources now here's we got his word
that that should be the church's
response for the tending to the wounds
part but then here's the church's other
response and dr. King brings this out we
also should speak to the conditions that
allow the road to be conducive for
robbers to hide and and beat people up
in the first place because if we don't
address that tomorrow somebody's gonna
be back on that road and robbers are
gonna be hiding out so the road is
conducive for that the curves and
everything right if it was modern day it
would be something like we got to put
lighting up on the road so it's not as
dark we got to have patrolmen coming so
it scares the robbers but we have to do
something to make the road safer for
those who are traveling that road right
otherwise we're gonna be back in this
situation again yeah an example of that
that comes to mind is is what DeRay
McKesson is doing with it can't wait yet
familiar was s like how you know he's
got these steps and things that are you
know immediately actionable in terms of
like changing how policing is done right
and he seems to be at the forefront of
addressing that ever since Ferguson yeah
which i think is a beautiful step and
okay here are some some handles that you
can actually implement and we can hold
you accountable and measures that are
available to okay police departments
what do we do
well here's here the eight that you can
actually look at look at how you train
your officers look at the current rules
and and things that are currently in
place that contribute to this type of
abuse and power let's attack those
things let's address those things you
know we don't want to put policemen in
harm's way anymore than they they are
currently that's not the intent of
reconstructing this whole thing it's to
look at which of these things are not
working I mean if we were looking at a
business right and a business decided to
to launch a startup decides to launch
they create a software and all what do
what do they recognize inherently in the
process they have a Minimum Viable
Product that they know is not going to
fly completely and perfectly when they
release it to market right they they
they release it knowing full well that
when the system begins to be in contact
with reality bugs are gonna show up but
they also in addition to that have a
plan of rapid implementation rapid
ideation to improve the system that's
the type of mindset we need to have when
we're talking about our judicial system
when we're talking about our policing
system is recognize that hey that what
you have in place okay it's a good start
you may have been well intended in these
rules and regulations and structures but
we see that the real world is showing
where this stuff is dysfunctional let's
change that let's let's implement rapid
you know tooling to improve what's there
and I think it can't wait is a great
suggestion in a great step in doing that
because police departments who've
already put that into effect we're
seeing positive benefits we're seeing
decrease and senseless police killings
yeah and I think what's great about it
is that it's not about rhetoric it's
data-driven so it's not just we need to
defund the police like what does that
even mean I mean I understand that's an
emotional reaction to seeing a
militarized police state that does
nothing but instill fear and exacerbate
whatever violence you know is happening
on the street right but to actually look
at the statistics and say what are the
levers that we can pull that will
actually make a difference and some of
them are counterintuitive like I heard
him talking about it on a podcast the
other day where you would think like
well you know if you just hire more
black police officers that'll solve it
but they realized that that isn't
effective until they reach something
like 34 percent of the police department
being black or you know instituting
psychological you know psych training or
whatever like they found out that that's
really not thought of like things that
you think might work and actually don't
but looking at the data can show you
like oh but these simple things every
Police Department can do actually could
make a huge difference in in reducing
fatality rates and and all of the abuse
instances yeah is there any part of it
can't wait that suggests the those who
are empower those who are have the power
to you know I don't know who would be
but captain's and commissioners because
if they've already bought into the
previous ideology mm-hmm that actually
has been passed on since the 1800s when
policing was designed to patrol the
slaves and protect the property of the
wealthy if that's been passed on mmm-hmm
so if they've bought into that and
that's who they are we're asking them to
buy into something that is foreign to
them right it's checks and balances
individuals and systems in which there
is a systemic problem right it's it
these are good solutions but you're
speaking to the broader problem of
dealing with the systemic aspect of it
and that goes to the psychology of the
people that are administering these
departments as well right I was talking
to a another person a police officer and
we were just talking about this was
actually a while back and we were just
talking about the the the emotional
health of police officers going into and
and having their their life be every
time they step out of the door it's
depending on their beat you know it
isn't known whether or not they're gonna
come home alright so that's the reality
they they live in and he and I in our
conversation he was sharing well here
are some things that I think we need to
improve and I thought it was really
interesting he said number one some of
the systemic issues for police officers
is number one good cops have to actually
be supported and and protected enough to
call out bad cops you know when you have
a fraternity and a subculture within the
precincts themselves where a good cop
doesn't feel safe and actually calling
out and holding accountable a bad cop
that's dysfunction in the system that
needs to change yeah on top of that you
have to have a support system where
again we're not even going to get into
you know the domestic violence of police
officers the the drug and alcohol abuse
that that's that systemic and you see
the divorce rate that you see from
police officers all of these things are
again flare up conditions that are
coming as a result of a dysfunctional
system so so we you know I'm all for and
and we support you know police officer
so this rhetoric of yeah you know you
got to be for the blue if you're if
you're protesting then you're not
supporting our police officers we got to
get past that you know it's no let's
look at the system in which these guys
and gals have to work and let's be
honest about how can we go about helping
them
when in this then also in addition to
what I've just listed also includes you
know their sense in their fear of
african-american males I mean there is a
huge subconscious I mean I've
experienced it in my whole life and and
and actually feeling that we're talking
about this and I and and if you look at
I've shared this before and that is
there is a secret language that all
African American men and women who work
in you know the white collar sector have
learned to speak and I'm not just
talking about being able to speak or you
know be proper and articulate I'm
talking about there is a way that when
we walk into a boardroom when we walk
into an environment when we walk down
the street and a white woman is
approaching us we've learned how to
signal to them that hey we're friendly
safe we're say yeah
you know you're not your non threat
we're non threat you're not an angry
black man exactly you know yeah that is
real aha and and so those things have to
be addressed and again the onus has to a
lot of the onus has to fall on white
America and not being so fragile in
those in that content right and and be
willing to step up and be willing to hey
if I'm passionate Italy arguing my point
across a boardroom table don't dismiss
it as an angry black man no let's
rigorously argue and deal with the
points that I'm ringing up because if my
counterpart who happens to be white is
just as adamant just as as committed and
expressing their point of view on this
on a particular issue they're going to
get a pass on that mm-hmm
you know there did this just they're
gonna they're gonna probably walk away
them from the meeting while he was he
was really really you know excited about
you know his his idea passion he's
passionate yeah right
not angry you have a double standard
right it's exhausting it's got to be
exhausting right some days I just don't
care when I'm going running and I have
to think about when I see that white
woman she doesn't realize she has more
power in the situation right I'm more
I'm more nervous than she is because if
she says anything she's gonna get the
benefit of the doubt yeah and sometimes
you're just tired you just you know
being a when you were gonna make a
church I'm not there now but when you
were gonna make a church it's like
working in a big company hmm and it's
the same thing and it's it's you have to
think about it you have to consider it
and it's mentally draining and some days
you just don't care some days I want to
be really really passionate and I just
don't care what you think you know but
then you can't be like that all the time
so you got to monitor that and it's just
those little microaggressions that if we
look at you said ten thousand feet let's
look at where we are going back to
earlier if you look at everything the
fatigue the anger it's it's about all of
this or what we're talking about
it's about the microaggressions it's
about being in the workplace and my
voice is muted by everyone else's voice
is heard it's about being in the inner
grocery store or in a store and being
surveilled having a surveillance we call
called the white gaze it's about when
you're hyper vigilance everywhere you go
it's like walking into Starbucks and the
guy over there just sitting he just
staring at you and you're like okay mmm
you know and you feel the eyes on you or
the guy that almost hit me
purposely come out of Whole Foods a few
months back purposely like he came
within inches did not slow down didn't
stop wait he slowed down we didn't stop
and he tried to make it seem like he
knew I'd already cleared but I'm inches
away from your car right and just those
daily occurrences just getting put into
the file cabinet right you know week
after week after week I think that
what's so special and unique about right
now is we're seeing every flavor in
color of that kind of experience and
writ large on social media because the
most
impactful and you're a filmmaker but the
most impactful and powerful filmmaking
that we're seeing right now is what's
coming out of everybody's cell phone you
know from the birder in Central Park
with that woman in the encounter that
they had from the cops that knocked over
that elderly white man in Buffalo and
then all the police officers that you
know resigned in their omertà to those
guys being fired like and everything in
between from the police the good police
officers who you know took a knee or
marched with the protesters the bad
behavior the good behavior and we're
having conversations about it yeah it
can't be a bad thing this Boyle is being
lanced it's out in the open right now
and we have this extraordinary
opportunity to leverage the energy
around this to actually do some good
with lasting change
it's interesting you brought that up
with the cops taking the knee it goes
back to coming to the table and really
relinquishing of power where those who
are protesting you know it could be a
young girl it could be a small petite
woman that's fiery she's holding on to
whatever power she has but that cop has
to be willing to relinquish power and he
may get backlash that you're showing a
sign of weakness but you notice whenever
they they do that it's usually peaceful
it's usually some reckons it's usually
something that shifts the the tenor of
the protests right but that was him or
whoever they are coming to the table at
that moment and the willingness to
relinquish some power and humble
themselves and say you know what I get
it I'm still gonna be a cop I get it but
I'm gonna kneel with you and it's
meeting them where they are and they see
now they're no longer threatened by your
power and as I think that's a perfect
example of what I was talking about
coming to the table if that can happen
behind the scenes when you come up with
legislation or police reform or
institutional reform in companies
corporations if that can happen then you
see some significant change in right and
lasting change lasting change but that
those
our dynamics are at play yeah and you
also mentioned the example of the
elderly gentleman being pushed over by
the police officers you know if you look
at that tape I think also I think it's a
great snapshot of the systemic
dysfunction as well because one guy is
one guy right he was on duty and he had
his orders were to march forward
he and his humanity recognized that what
just happened and in his humanity wanted
to stop to help him but his whoever was
the commanding officer at that time or
whoever literally physically said no you
continue to march forward mm-hmm that I
think again it tells a strong story of
just how insidious how complicated yet
how urgent the problem we're facing is
and and we have to be willing to stop
looking at the status quo or looking at
our job as as normal as usual and start
again challenging what is not working
and taking the time to figure out how
can we do it better my hope and and and
my encouragement is I believe we can you
know I believe that we are intelligent
enough and we are compassionate enough
to actually make inroads and and solve
this thing I truly do but it's going to
take courageous voices and a staying
power that that will allow us to
eventually get escape velocity one to
get off the ground and into escape
velocity and fight through all of that
natural resistance that we've been
talking about this whole time to the
point where we get to an inflection
point that then allows this thing to
really take on a life of its own we're
nowhere near that yet and so this
gravitational pull is the area that
we're in and we have to just understand
that and recognize we're in for a fight
so let's buckle up let's lock arms and
let's stay committed
yeah I think it's gonna require an
appreciation of the incredible
complexity of all of it to when you were
speaking there I was thinking about the
situation in Flint where the the was at
the chief and the cops were marching
with the protesters and a distinguishing
factor there at least according to my
understanding is that the police
officers live in the community there
whereas due to socio-economic disparity
a lot of police officers can't afford to
live in the communities in which they
police which creates a lack of
connectivity to the people that they're
supposed to be protecting and serving
yeah right so that's just another like
layer or issue that needs to be unpacked
and addressed then goes B you know
that's almost beyond like how do we
solve economic disparities you know
police officers can live in the same
area where they're patrolling like these
companies these problems are huge huge
huge and I like what it feel has a
program I call them the for ELLs and
speak to that a little bit more and I
talk about okay what do we do now you
know you know the eight can't wait I
think is a great start right but which
is I think is a subset of campaign zero
campaign zero exactly exactly
great website and there's some other I
can't think of it right now but
resources but those are two great
resources that I think people can go to
and look at okay what can I do now where
I'm at because a lot of people feel
defenseless a lot of people feel
hopeless and don't feel like their voice
counts or what they do would actually
matter and that's not the case and so
hopefully in the show nose we'll be able
to you know give the links to
organizations that are bipartisan and
that are just there their boots on the
ground really trying to figure this
thing out
I think would be important but but Phil
can you speak to just the the the for
ELLs that kind of helps people walk
through this process yeah we've heard a
couple of those ELLs to listen and to
learn
that all the time just a little
background we're watching a film in
class four years ago MLK class and they
showed Emmett Till and that's when I
first realized wait a minute Emmett Till
reminds me of my grandfather my
grandfather's body would've probably
looked like that and we broke up into
small groups and I shared with my class
like two classmates I can't see Emmett
Till without seeing my grandfather and
it kind of shocked them so they'd be
they were intently listening to me they
were in a context where they were
learning from a Korean MLK scholar not
Joon Lee about an african-american
pastor scholar theologian MLK so they
were listening and learning that was
happening at the same time they were
learning from my story but they were
learning theology and ethics Christian
theology and ethics about dr. King from
a Korean man from people of color but
what what shocked me would never happen
before him I'd never seen this was when
they began to cry I'd never seen a white
person moved or feel for mine or my
people's pain as relates to racism they
were in tears to the point where one kid
said as you see your grandfather in
Emmett Till I see my grandfather in the
men who killed him and that's a huge
that's huge right did I shared with the
whole class the whole class
not the whole class but many people in
class began to just be in tears hmm and
so I just wanted to just what I had
experienced in that class that day and I
said they were listening they were
learning they lamented and for me in
this journey to what do we do that's the
sole work that needs to happen that
makes up the sole work but the inner
work because we can jump into fixing
stuff and compound the issue because we
don't understand the issue we don't
understand the depth of the pain we
don't feel it we're just in here trying
to fix a problem that we think we can
take care of real quick
then it's the labor and the reason why
the lament part is so important I don't
know anybody who sustains something
that's that causes change without
passion without a burden without
something in the gut that drives them
right so now the labor but the labor is
depending on context the person's
influence their relationships who they
have you know it depends on where they
are and in your life so like somebody
can have a platform a huge platform so
their labor could be as you said earlier
bringing and making sure it's diverse
voices or black voices have a platform
she's sharing a platform whatever a
teacher I got my school some of them are
now forced to relearn some of their
theological positions perspective
they're being challenged by people of
color than perspectives of color so now
they're having to diversify their
reading list in their curriculums
schools are now having to bring in
change up the dynamics of their
administration their Board of Trustees
these are some things that need to
happen but those things won't be
sustained without the inner work the
listening learning the lamenting and so
the little labor part it depends on
context where you are for somebody it
could mean joining an organization in
your local community that is doing the
work of social justice for somebody else
it could be funding as well as how you
handle your social media platform being
responsible there I mean it could mean a
number of things and I tell people in
the church it starts your labor should
start with prayer if I'm praying for
this daily you need to be praying for
this daily - and again on the labor part
as well you know with another
high-profile example is the co-founder
of Reddit you know deciding to write I
saw that yeah honey yeah honey and says
you know what okay I I recognize my
privilege
I recognize the position that I'm in
I'm going to you know again he was more
of a head of a cheer role and things of
that nature but he's like I am going to
use this as an opportunity to remove
myself and then strongly recommend that
an african-american person be put in
this place not in some affirmative
action type way you know but but
recognizing that hey look this is
something that I'm going to be a part of
the solution and not a part of the
problem through my complicitous or my
because I don't know what I can do
decide to remain frozen and do nothing
he's like I'm gonna try this I'm gonna
do this and this is an example but I'm
also gonna call out anyone else who
isn't in a position where they can
purposely and willfully render or give
over to them the power that's necessary
to right the ship faster you know those
moves have to continue to take place as
well and again this isn't about you know
giving black people something that they
don't deserve or unqualified for because
you hear that argument too you hear that
argument against affirmative action you
hear that argument again a lot of these
different problems well you know these
people aren't not really qualified to do
this so that's unfair that they would
take a spot from someone who's more
deserving not even getting into all of
that well what what I'm what I the point
that I really want to highlight is know
there are enough qualified African
Americans and if you want even broaden
it out other minority groups who are
just as capable of excelling in that
role but if your networks aren't healthy
enough so that when you go through the
hiring process most of those jobs in
influential positions are done through
network it's the buddy system all right
and then they kick the tires through HR
right but they've got people been hired
I mean I I've had the experience we know
that that's how it works until your
network becomes diversified and I would
challenge I used to challenge executives
and and and pastors this I said if
you're in a hiring position and there's
a role that needs to be hired for but
it's an important role what do you
normally do and they they normally pick
up the phone and they
are calling their buddies Yeah right
good who's good who do you got who you
know and then I say well you know the
first five people you call think about
it think about your first five people in
your your rolodex or your your contacts
list now I get them to think about it
and then I said all right now what color
are they if all five of those people who
you would pick up the phone and call
their first five calls all of them look
like you recognize that in that moment
you're still now perpetuating the
problem because you're only exhausting
and exploring a network that's going to
continue to produce the same thing
instead why not in this time actively
begin to diversify your network it could
even start there mmm this guy from
reddit I don't know if he should if he
should have done that I don't know
because if he removes himself he's
already an advocate he removes himself
and brings in this black guy is this
black guy gonna be at the table by
himself with no other voice advocating
with him so rather than removing himself
from the table I think they should add
the more seats to the table I think that
because I don't want to come into a
context where the guy that was just
advocating for me he leaves and I find
myself there now you're the target no
one no one else really feels the way he
feels now I'm fighting a battle but he's
gone well the argument that gets thrown
around is that this is a performance of
white guilt for the purpose of virtue
signaling mmm-hmm and and that's where
the pendulum can't swing the other way
white guilt of doing that it's like yeah
but here's where I extend a lot of grace
it's almost like you look at a kid who's
just learning how to ride a bike if they
have a commitment and intent to learn to
ride this bike right the initial push
off is gonna look rocky it's gonna look
shaky and it's not gonna look pretty
they're gonna make a lot of mistakes
they're gonna fall I see a lot of
movements and gestures just like I see
that out of the gate it's not going to
be necessarily right and pretty and
it could error on the side of white
guilt but let's not demonize it let's
not throw it away but instead let's just
again continue to solve for the problem
mm-hmm
salt you know its outcome thinking
versus process thinking if we just think
about the process we'll get overwhelmed
and we'll get discouraged and we'll shut
down but if we think okay everything
that we do everything that we test
everything that we we apply it always
has to be laid against the outcome the
desired result we want and make informed
decisions based upon how well we're
moving in that direction I think that is
the that's the momentum that's the
posture that's the flow I think we need
to be able to be in and sustained but
but I also think that if you if we don't
rush if we don't move too quickly we can
avoid many of those mistakes so we
talked about listen learn lament part of
that is to give the space of processing
so we're not out of the gate trying to
you know swing the pendulum to the other
side and just right the ship right away
that's the whole point of that process
and I shared that yesterday on my social
media slow down like we just experienced
trauma all of us experienced trauma mmm
so they're gonna be those decisions that
are made to write the ship and they're
gonna and some of them want to compound
the issue but if we if we process this
thing together slow down and I would say
listen to the voices of color will make
less mistakes we won't come out of the
gate exacerbating the problem but isn't
the fear that we can't allow this energy
and this momentum to dissipate yeah that
is the fear but I don't think I don't
think it will is I'm not saying we don't
do anything mm-hmm I'm just saying let's
not try to like fix everything right
away of course in that processing will
make wiser decisions now this is where
as a pastor I share you know this is
where I'm allowing God to lead me this
is where I'm
not just lead me but us in in community
as we wrestle with things like even
right now as we're talking we're
processing we have different maybe some
different views and suggestions and
stuff like that but in this context
there can come there can be something to
be we can give birth to something right
so the process doesn't have to be long I
mean it could be weeks it could be a
matter of weeks but it just like take
you take out time and let's let's just
do this together rather than trying to
fix it cuz we're not gonna fix it right
right away this is I don't believe that
this gets fixed in my generation I'm a
cynic I believe we can make it better
for the next generation and when I say
generally maybe in my lifetime the next
generation those Gen Z's they have a
better starting point everything I do is
not for me or for us necessarily is for
my niece it's for my godson so when
they're older they don't have to have
the same conversation they may have some
conversations but not the same
conversation so that's what I'm thinking
is critical that we don't we don't try
to fix it today mm-hmm I don't think
they lose the urgency I think because
you know I'm not saying wait until like
next year or anything like that I'm just
saying let's just make sure we're we're
taking the right steps
I believe the healing part is is
critical man I think making certain
decisions from up from a hurt angry or
traumatized space can actually make the
problem worse
um is I think really tending to that
because the civil rights movement the
work that they put in even before it
started the work that they put in behind
the scenes the women before King even
came on board the ship was already
rolling and then he comes on board and
he's this dynamic personality but even
every step of the way every week every
month they were strategy they were
meeting praying strategizing and so if
they can do that and give us a model
mm-hmm then I think we can do the same
thing
yeah and I agree with you on that I
think what I would like to add at least
highlight is I think it's an both I
think the waiting the allows the healing
because I think that's I mean that's
that's the point we we I think all agree
to that that's important the lamenting
part of the the for ELLs you've got
listen you got learn you've got lament
you know which is mourning many times
you you have people from different sides
they'll have to mourn the the power and
the the the Suprema the white supremacy
that they didn't know they were
perpetuating okay they how the world was
the way they thought the is different so
definitely I think that is that is a
necessary part and process but more I
mean pragmatically and I see it as an
both yeah that's right yeah we don't
want to rush things so that we make a
lot of you know unforced errors and sort
of speak but at the same time I think we
we continue to move in ways and in if
things happen and they make mistakes
let's not demonize that's the point that
I wanted to really highlight is okay if
something happens and someone I mean we
see this in administration's all the
time you know you go into the Affordable
Care Act right and this thing rolls out
and it was far from perfect far from
perfect
but instead of again seeing it as a roll
out and then identifying what works what
doesn't and then changing political
parties demonize and and want to throw
the baby out with the bathwater and we
see that happening over and over again
from the left to the right right to the
left we see it in social groups
different dynamics I just keep wanting
to advocate that can't be our approach
because like you said rich the problem
is too too complex for us to have lazy
logic in this and be stuck in our silos
so much that we spend more energy
defending our point than solving the
problem another switching gears a little
bit another narrative that's out there
is that this problem is not for black
people to solve it's for white people to
solve so what is the role of white
America in redressing this other than
you know that you talked about the ELLs
and we need to educate people we need to
appreciate the complexity of this we
need time to heal we need you know a
longer conversation that isn't
bifurcated around political lines like
how do we how does how do the white
people listening to this wrap their
heads around how they can be a most
productive member of this you know
movement I think you know I go back and
forth because I believe that is voices
of color that need to lead mm-hmm
because we feel it you know this idea
you can't lead me someplace you've never
been or you can't give to me what you've
never had a percent mmm it would just
it's preposterous right otherwise you
know so there's a learning from voices
of color but I think taking the power
and the privilege and and and being a
part of helping to reach the white the
broader white community I think right
now that's that's a with it whether it's
in government those congressmen and
women using their positions to reach
them family members on the family level
reaching them and the corporate in
corporations reaching them I think
because we can't reach them our job we
can share we can put pressure on we can
protest we can we can do all these
things we can write books but they're
not gonna listen to us necessarily so I
think one way this is just one it's not
the only way this is one one thing is I
asked you know white friends you have to
be the voice to reach the people that
we're not going to be able to reach on
all these levels wherever your influence
is that's that's one way because I don't
know what else we can do
III really don't if you look at
literature you look at music you look at
movies you look at marches we've done it
peacefully we've done it angrily we've
kneeled we've knelt we've fist in the
air we've used our bodies in ways that
that's how we didn't that's one of the
primary resources we have our bodies
we've done everything we know to do and
we're still here
not just incidents but a culture right I
think it takes the white allies or
whatever word you want to use for that
to be the voices advocating in
solidarity to the white community
because they're not gonna listen to us
necessarily not all some will but the
masses won't listen to us mm-hmm yeah to
add to that I think that's a great point
you know we talked about dr. Martin
Luther King during the civil rights
movement and we forget about another
voice that was even more demonized but I
think was was as equally an integral
part in advancing was Malcolm X right
and even to this day you know he that
name is still demonized and a lot of
people when they hear that name they're
immediately
you know fearful because of what he
stood for but what people what isn't
what is less known about him especially
in the tail end of his of his movement
and his platform was he you know saw and
started to to to bring different
nationalities and cultures together and
and he shared something that I think is
is important and it speaks to your your
question about what do white people do
in this in this moment and one thing he
recognized is right now of course
everybody's binging Netflix there's a
Netflix or no I think it's on HBO but
the Defiant ones it's it's a four part
episode or series on the relationship
between dr. Dre and Jimmy Iovine right
to moguls in the the hip-hop or the
music industry and how they come
together and
you know they're taking over the world
with bees and apple and all that stuff
right well interesting and the point
that Malcolm X really tried to highlight
that I see illustrated in their
relationship is at some point the Jimmy
Iovine saw and recognized the talent and
the ability of dr. Dre and it wasn't a
posture of let me reach back and down
and pull this guy up it was never that
what it was was wait a minute I see and
identify in in in in dr. Dre the same
love and passion and raw talent and
ability even better than my own and and
I'm going to actually use my my in to
nurture and cultivate this guy that that
whole relationship is powerful we need
more of that because here you had Jimmy
Iovine who was already on the in who
himself you know came from modest
backgrounds but then at the height of
his power recognizing someone else and
saying let me mentor let me and it
wasn't again this back and down it
wasn't charity he saw how he could make
money with dr. Dre right I mean it saw
that this guy was valuable but but this
guy also needs a seat at the table in
Nautica exploitive way exactly saying
right now not only in a partnership way
and in a way that's loving too because
not to not to like spoiler you know to
spoiled whoever wants to watch it but
you saw in the narrative of dr. Dre's
life many missteps that that you you
know it's like wow he could have blown
it up here he could have blown it up
here in here he still had a guy who was
like look I'm all in with you because
III see the value so extrapolating on
that the message that you're trying to
convey when like distill that down to
the point okay that relates to Malcolm X
so those so the point thank you for
actually helping me bring the point is
Malcolm X recognized
the importance of people white people in
power aligning themselves with black
people
hmm and sharing the power right and and
not doing it in a way that it's charity
not doing it in a way that it's what
we're deeming as white guilt but
actually taking the time to recognize
seeing the humanity of another person
and recognizing in the backdrop of
inequality I'm gonna ride with this
person right come he'll a highway I got
it one of the differentiating factors
between what's happening now and the
civil rights movement of the late 1960s
is that there is no Malcolm X or Martin
Luther King we don't have a singular
voice to galvanize the movement around
there but but at the same time there's a
lot of interesting voices out there
right now they're just more dispersed
it's not as centralized as before and
I've I found myself wondering like would
it be better if there was one person
that we're kind of pivoting around I
mean that doesn't seem to be the reality
right now but maybe one of the things we
can kind of wind this conversation down
with is who are those interesting voices
out there if people want to broaden
their you know information silo to
expose themselves to interesting people
of color I think of Tony he see Coates
you know I just listen to him on that on
as reclines podcasts the other day I was
amazing yeah I think I think he he he's
a voice that that has to be seriously
considered and listened to but I think I
don't know if we'll ever really go back
to that model hmm
you know in our community we say every
time we have a leader they kill him on
some level yeah
it's sad but true but either physically
kill them or their their character their
reputation they'll find a way and then
that that kills the whole movement
because we've put everything around this
one central voice good point and so when
you have multiple voices and I think
it's important if you have multiple
voices you have someone who has an
expertise in this area they can bring
that to the table you have someone over
here who has an expertise in this area
they can bring that to the table I'm
trying to think of my whole library just
going through my head and everything's
if you can't think of anybody now if you
got maybe guys email me and I'll put it
in the shoutouts
Willie Jennings mmm is phenomenal he's a
theologian he's phenomenal he has a book
called the Christian imagination he has
a controversial lecture his
controversial if you just look at the
title it's called can white people be
saved and he's not talking about white
people in terms in necessarily ethnicity
based on my ideology where we talk about
white supremacy and people who subscribe
to that either even subconsciously but
in some it breaks down whiteness and its
impact on the whole world
from colonialism to now and he does it
theologically J Cameron Carter is
another theologian
that's brilliant he was at Duke you know
he's at Indiana University I believe so
there are a number of voices and many of
them don't get as much airplay as they
should but these these these guys are
brilliant I think of uh who died I think
I shared a name female woman
well Angela riii love Angela rise she
she's she's brilliant as well you're
outspoken I'll send you yeah okay yeah
mm-hmm firing as anyone well you know
actually I I actually agree with with
Phil when you're saying that I think the
model has to be slightly different there
needs to be a hybrid model moving
forward I don't think there will be one
person to galvanize and be that one
voice but and this is my crazy creative
side coming out
I when I look at movements and organs
and organisms and how you see systems
operate autonomously but continue to
thrive and exist for example you you
look at let's say again and this is
crazy see if pull me back in if I go too
far but you you look at paleo you look
at you know the raw you look at
movements like you know plant strong
plant based there isn't just one person
who everyone is following and keeping
those movements alive no it's it's a
it's a it's a concept is an ideal and
anti ideology but it is a framework by
which people in by themselves can take
ownership of and then create a lifestyle
around it and they in in in in doing
that they can augment that with
resources from other voices so there any
their their education or their thirst
for knowledge and mastery is what drives
the movement with them and then you have
that happening collectively among
thousands and millions of people and
that's what allows a movement to exist I
truly believe that is what's going to
have to take place in this is that at
some point at the fundamental personal
level everyone's gonna have to say this
is going to become a lifestyle for me
and then as I come up against blocks or
roadblocks or confusion that's when I'm
going to reach out and I'm gonna listen
to voices that I think are credible and
then I'm gonna take like an old pastor
used to say you know he's just taking
advice it's like eating chicken he says
you you eat the meat throw the bones
away you know and that's you know got a
funny but but that's that's I think the
mentality that we have to have we have
to say I'm gonna take personal ownership
of it and I'm gonna live it out
regardless of what other people think
and say or do and I'm going to purposely
orient my life where I'm gonna keep
educating myself in this lifestyle in
this way of life so that I'm better at
it and then ultimately I'm blessing and
impacting in a positive way the lives
around me mm-hmm
beautifully put man
beautifully put well I think we should
put a pin in it I think we covered a lot
of ground here I do want to point out
that a good place for people to start
especially if you want to learn more
about Phil is to read your recent blog
post this is America I thought that was
super powerful
thank you and you basically you once
again not mincing words like you just
break down this whole situation and in a
way that I think is is powerful but also
digestible for anybody to read so any
final thoughts before we end it today
what I wanted to I I love you Richie or
your brother from another mother we you
know I just say just your heart and for
allowing us on the podcast and just
again having this kind of conversation
and just seeing you and your heart and
the steadfastness of the mission you're
on with the platform you've been given
and that you're blessed to cultivate
thank you thank you because I think that
this these are the sorts of things that
need to happen
I appreciate it consistently yeah thanks
man I'm just you know I'm doing this is
imperfectly as anybody and trying to
learn as I go like I'm doing this for my
own personal edification as much for for
anything else and you know it's
incumbent upon me just like it is for
everybody else to try to be as open
minded to humble ourselves and and and -
you know broaden our aperture on all of
this I really appreciate you guys coming
here today and sharing openly and
honestly and from the heart your
experience in your perspective and I
hope you guys come back and talk to me a
little bit more I appreciate being here
man this was this was good it's good for
me you say what can white people do I
think you're doing it you're sharing the
the at the table we're sitting at an
actual table but if it feels like a
partnership in this conversation you
know I mean and I think that's important
yeah thanks
appreciate that all right so if you're
digging on these guys the best way to
track them down and
find them Phil Allen jr. on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram and Phil Phil
Allen jr. calm as well right and Byron
Byron CC yeah
Byron CEO that's that thanks you guys I
appreciate it and I hope that you
continue your advocacy thank you thank
you alright peace
[Music]
you